.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ein Diplom für eine neue Zukunft.
Das sind die ersten Abgänger einer
kleinen Hotelfachschule in Ruanda.
Gegründet von der Schweizerin
Jackie Helfenberger.
Heute weiss ich,
warum ich weitermache
und um jeden Franken bitte:
Damit das hier machbar wird.
Damit die jungen Leute professio-
nelle Karrieren starten können.
Ich kann nur alle dazu ermuntern,
dasselbe zu machen.
Es ist möglich.
Ich bin keine Millionärin.
Mit viel Passion und Herzblut
kann man etwas bewegen.
Viel Leidenschaft haben
auch diese jungen Schweizerinnen.
Jackie Helfenberger
hat die zehn Bäckerlehrlinge
für einen Austausch
nach Ruanda gebracht.
Denn in Zukunft
will sie an ihrer Schule
auch Bäcker ausbilden.
Ruanda ist ihre zweite Heimat
und Helfen ihre Passion.
Längst hat sie ihr Herz
ans kleine Land im Herzen Afrikas
verschenkt.
(Mann) Hello, Pascal.
- Hello.
Welcome to Rwanda.
On va faire une photo?
Vor drei Jahren
landete sie zum ersten Mal hier.
Heute betritt sie zum elften Mal
ruandischen Boden.
Jackie, wie ist das für dich,
wenn du ankommst?
Es ist immer mehr ein Heimkommen.
Ich fühle mich wirklich
wie zu Hause. Es ist megaschön.
Jackie Helfenberger
pendelt seit zwei Jahren
zwischen der Schweiz und Ruanda.
Mit ihrem Sangira-Hilfswerk will sie
hier die Berufsbildung fördern.
Jahrelang
führte sie ein Sprachreisebüro.
Doch dann kam die Pandemie
und zwang die Branche in die Knie.
Sie sattelte um
und nutzt heute
ihre Erfahrung und ihr Netzwerk
für Entwicklungszusammenarbeit.
Jetzt bin ich gerade im Wechsel.
Jetzt ziehe ich den Ruandahut an.
Jetzt bin ich hier und nehme
mein ruandisches Telefon raus
und fange an,
meine Termine anzurufen:
"Hallo, ich bin hier."
"Wie sieht es morgen aus,
können wir uns treffen?"
Dann flutscht alles automatisch.
Ich bin sehr gelassen geworden.
Es kommt immer gut.
Ruanda will ein Tourismusland werden.
Statt an den Völkermord von 1994,
soll man an Gorillas
und unberührte Natur denken.
Fast 1 Mio. Tutsis
wurden damals abgeschlachtet.
Nicht zuletzt deshalb fehlt dem Land
heute eine ganze Generation Menschen
und damit auch Fachkräfte.
40 % der Ruanderinnen und Ruander
sind unter 15.
Berufsbildung
ist deshalb heute besonders gefragt.
Wir besuchen einen,
der damals das Land verliess
und später zurückkehrte.
Das sind Cakeformen und für den
Valentinstag haben wir die Herzen.
Seit Olivier Sogokuru
zurück ist aus Belgien,
betreibt er in Kigali eine Bäckerei.
Hier soll
ein Teil der Schweizer Bäckerinnen
nächste Woche
Kuchen und Brote backen.
Ah, meine Wasserwaage.
Wofür ist das?
- Das ist eine Zukunftsidee.
Ich brauche irgendwann
einen neuen Ofen.
Machen Sie den selber?
- Den mache ich selber.
Oui. Je le fais moi-même.
Aber den Brenner
hole ich vielleicht aus Belgien.
Das muss einer sein,
wie bei dem drinnen.
Ich brauche nur den Brenner.
Wenn das alles schön aufgemacht ist,
wird das gut.
Dann kommen wir
den Kuchen probieren.
Wenn man etwas nicht zur Hand hat,
wissen wir uns immer zu helfen.
Das müssen wir halt.
Wer hier weiterkommen will,
muss erfinderisch sein.
Das werden
auch die angehenden Bäckerinnen
aus der Schweiz bald erfahren.
Noch bleiben drei Tage
bis zur Ankunft der zehn Lernenden.
Jackie und ihr lokales Team
haben noch viel zu tun.
Wir brauchen neun ...
... zehn, elf, zwölf ...
... 13 Imishanana.
Es hilft der Kreativität,
nicht alles im Detail zu planen.
Ich muss noch meine Ansprache
auf Kinyarwanda vorbereiten.
Pas beaucoup.
- Non.
Ils te connaissent dejà.
Du bist hier in einem Land,
in dem man Englisch,
Kinyarwanda und Französisch spricht.
Du aber repräsentierst
die deutsche Sprache.
Oui.
D'accord?
- Mhm.
Ich schlage vor,
du machst eine Mischung aus allem
und schaffst dadurch
eine neue Kultur,
die für die Zukunft Afrikas steht.
Ich finde das eine gute Idee,
die Sprachen zu mischen.
Ich mag Sprachen sehr.
Das repräsentiert mich gut.
Was ist deine Rolle hier?
Wie siehst du dich?
Ich bin eine Brücke.
Ich sehe mich als Brücke
zwischen den beiden Kulturen
und ich sehe hier
ein riesiges Potenzial,
dass wir davon lernen können, was
die Ruander und Ruanderinnen können,
und dass sie
auch von uns lernen können.
Z.B., wenn es
um die Rolle der Frauen geht.
Nirgendwo in Afrika gibt es
mehr Frauen in Führungspositionen.
Eine Folge des Völkermordes, bei dem
überwiegend Männer ums Leben kamen.
In der Frauenförderung
könne die Schweiz von Ruanda lernen,
vielleicht mit einer Frauenquote.
Es braucht einfach
eine gewisse Quote oder Bevorzugung,
um den Change mal zu starten.
Der ist hier ja sehr brutal passiert.
- Eben.
Dass so viele Frauen in Charge sind,
ist ja auch eine Folge davon.
Ja. Und jetzt haben wir 60 %
per Verfassung in der Regierung.
Wir haben 40 % CEOs.
Die machen einen tollen Job.
Wir in der Schweiz
sind noch bei ungefähr 5 %.
Also würde ich sagen: "Frauen,
kommt nach Ruanda und schaut,
was die Frauen hier leisten."
* Ruhige Musik *
Eine dieser erfolgreichen
Geschäftsfrauen Ruandas
will Jackie heute treffen.
Eh, Grace.
Grace Nyirabarinda.
Salut.
Die beiden kennen sich schon lange.
Sie sind Freundinnen geworden.
Welcome.
Grace betreibt
am Rande der Stadt eine Schneiderei,
in der sie Frauen aus Ruanda und
dem benachbarten Burundi beschäftigt.
Sie will diesen damit
eine Zukunft ermöglichen.
Hier lässt Jackie
traditionelle Kleider nähen -
für die grosse Diplomfeier,
die Ende der Woche ansteht.
Als junge Frau hat Grace
den Völkermord von Ruanda 1994
erlebt und überlebt.
Die Wunden
sind bis heute nicht verheilt.
Darüber reden sei wichtig und helfe,
sagt sie.
We wear it like that.
- Ah, okay.
Heute können wir
wie Schwestern zusammenarbeiten.
Mhm.
Wie ist das für Sie,
darüber zu reden?
Does it feel hard?
- For me?
Für mich ist das okay.
Es ist nicht mehr schwer.
Bevor ich ihnen vergeben hatte,
war es nicht einfach.
Aber langsam
konnte mein Herz heilen.
Yeah.
Bevor dein Herz nicht geheilt ist,
ist es schwierig,
mit jemandem zusammenzuarbeiten,
der deine Familie getötet hat.
Das war nicht einfach.
Aber heute ist es gut.
Der Völkermord
bleibt aber ein heikles Thema,
das man
kaum beim ersten Gespräch anspricht.
... one to forgive another one.
Mir haben uns zuerst
zwei-, dreimal getroffen.
Dann merkte ich, dass sie offen ist,
darüber zu sprechen.
Und ...
Dann wagte ich es auch,
Fragen zu stellen.
Ich habe schon vielen
Fragen gestellt,
merkte dann aber,
dass ich auch die Antworten
verdauen können muss.
Wenn man Vertrauen zu jemandem hat,
erzählen sie einem auch davon.
Das sind manchmal
so schlimme Geschichten,
dass man
ein paar Tage daran nagt.
Ich hörte dann auf,
zu viele Fragen zu stellen.
Einfach so weit,
dass ich es auch verdauen kann.
Wir sind alle Ruander,
sprechen die gleiche Sprache.
Warum sollten wir uns umbringen?
Ich merke: Es gibt viele Tabuthemen
in diesem Land.
Der Völkermord ist eines.
So darf man die beiden Bevölkerungs-
gruppen der Hutus und Tutsis
nicht mehr beim Namen nennen.
Offiziell gibt es nur noch Ruander.
Wie schnell die Emotionen
beim Thema Völkermord
trotz alledem
auch heute noch hochgehen,
merken wir
bei unserem nächsten Treffen.
Wir fahren an einen Ort, der wie kaum
ein anderer an den Genozid erinnert:
das Hôtel des Mille Collines
in Kigali.
Es ist der Ausgangspunkt für
den berühmten Film "Hotel Ruanda".
Dank eines mutigen Hoteldirektors
haben hier 1'200 Tutsis
die Gräueltaten der Hutus überlebt.
Hier hat Jackie
eine Verabredung mit einem Schweizer,
der lange für eine Entwicklungsbank
in Ruanda arbeitete
und jetzt als Tourist da ist.
Und wie fühlt es sich an,
nach 40 Jahren wieder hier zu sein?
Fast 40 Jahre, oder?
- Es sind ziemlich genau 40 Jahre.
Es sind gemischte Gefühle,
wenn du so direkt fragst,
wie es sich anfühlt.
Einerseits ...
Man erkennt die Stadt nicht mehr.
Bruno Baeriswyl
hat grosse Fragezeichen,
wie nachhaltig
Ruandas Wirtschaftsboom sei
und legt den Finger
auf einen wunden Punkt:
die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich.
Sobald man
von den geteerten Strassen weggeht,
kommt man eigentlich
in ein Ruanda wie vor 40 Jahren.
Auch von ...
... der Armut der Leute her.
Von der Lebensweise der Leute her.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
auf dem Land ...
... ist sehr wenig
bis nichts passiert.
Ich habe eine gewisse Skepsis,
ob man da wirklich nachhaltig
etwas gemacht hat,
respektive, ob man jetzt
etwas Nachhaltiges macht.
Jackies Partner Bobito
kränkt diese Sicht.
Er vertritt die Meinung,
sein Land sei im Aufbruch.
Siehst du nicht,
dass die Entwicklung da ist?
Ich sage nicht,
dass die für alle da ist.
Aber von der Statistik her,
wo wir jetzt sind ...
Also, Entschuldigung,
man kann nur blind sein,
wenn man diese Wirkung
nicht mal sieht.
Jackie Helfenberger
versucht zu schlichten
und lenkt zurück zu ihrem Thema:
der Bildung.
Ich denke,
mit den Mitteln, die sie haben,
haben sie schon vieles gemacht.
Deshalb sind wir auch hier
und haben jetzt die Hotellerieschule
in Nyamasheke aufgebaut.
Ich denke,
du kannst überall Sämchen säen,
aber das Zugpferd ist Kigali.
Ich denke, über kurz oder lang
zieht das alle mit.
Jackies Schlichten hilft nicht.
Vom Wirtschaftsboom
kommt man auf den Genozid
und schliesslich
auf die bis heute umstrittene Rolle
der
internationalen Entwicklungshilfe.
Das Gespräch eskaliert.
Wir müssen die Kamera ausschalten.
Das Treffen macht mir deutlich:
Auch bald 30 Jahre danach
bleiben viele Fragen offen.
Ein neuer Tag beginnt:
Die Bäckerlehrlinge aus der Schweiz
sollen heute in Kigali landen.
Längst ist der Flieger da, doch
von den zehn Bäckerinnen keine Spur.
Hier braucht es schon eindeutig
mehr Geduld als zu Hause, oder?
Ja, es braucht
etwas mehr Geduld als zu Hause. Mhm.
Es braucht schon etwas mehr Geduld.
- Hattest du die schon immer?
Ja, ich habe viel.
Aber auch ich habe eine Limite.
Aber im Moment habe ich noch Geduld.
Ich versuche, im Jetzt zu sein.
Auch Jackie Helfenbergers
Partner Bobito wird langsam nervös.
Er versucht,
seine Beziehungen spielen zu lassen.
Hallo?
Die Bäckerinnen hängen am Zoll fest.
Was ist passiert?
Wir haben viele Schuhe dabei,
als Geschenke.
Jetzt wollen sie
den Wert dieser Schuhe wissen.
Jeder Koffer
hat ein paar Schuhe drin.
Wir haben ein ...
... Zertifikat dabei,
dass die für einen guten Zweck sind.
Aber jetzt
wollen sie noch mehr Papier.
Vielleicht kann Bobito das lösen,
mit einem Anruf ...
... von Ruanda nach Ruanda.
Tatsächlich wirkt der Anruf Wunder.
Ihr habt es geschafft.
Endlich hat es geklappt.
Hallo. Wie heisst du schon wieder?
- Thalia.
Thalia.
Wow!
Hallo.
Alle sind hier. Ich bin zufrieden.
Seid ihr alle gesund? Hoi.
- Hoi.
Ui, ui, ui,
ihr hattet einen langen Weg.- Ja.
Die zehn Lernenden sind da
und mit ihnen Berge von Gepäck.
Nicht nur Schuhe, sondern
auch Backutensilien und Zutaten.
Ruanda wird nun für einen Monat
ihre neue Heimat sein.
Die jungen Frauen sind alle
zum ersten Mal in Afrika.
Junge Bäcker haben sich keine
für den Austausch interessiert.
Das Abenteuer
beginnt am nächsten Morgen
mit dem Besuch eines lokalen Marktes.
Die Lernenden sollen herausfinden,
welche Zutaten man hier kaufen kann
und welche nicht.
Damit sie auch wissen,
welche Rezepte sich später
überhaupt umsetzen lassen.
Ihr Aufenthalt in Ruanda wird von
einer Schweizer Stiftung getragen.
Ziel ist der Austausch von Wissen.
Beide Seiten sollen am Ende
von der anderen profitieren können.
Probier es mal.
Is this the same thing?
Können wir das essen?
- Can they eat it?
(Mann) No problem.
- Can we eat it?
Was ist da? Das ist Mehl.
Das ist Mehl.
- Ja.
Nice?
- Yes, very nice.
Ja.
- Perfect.
Perfect?
- Was ist es?
Sojamehl.
- Soy?- Ja.
Ja, das ist gut. It's very nice.
- Soy flour.- Soy flour?
Yes.
Es dauert nicht lange
und schon erfasst sie
das ruandische Shoppingfieber.
Bananas?
- Okay.
Come here.
Das sind die Tea Trees.
Tree Tomato.
Süss-säuerliche Früchte.
Sehr lecker.
This is passion fruit.
Ja.
Passionsfrucht?
- Nein, danke.
Ich habe das schon mal probiert
und mag es nicht.
I'm sorry.
- Test it. Test it. It's okay.
Wie ist der erste Eindruck?
- Es ist krass.
Es hat so viele Leute und Gerüche.
Überflutet von neuen Eindrücken
verlassen sie den Markt:
Die Arbeit ruft.
Die Lernenden sollen ein erstes Mal
ihre Berufskenntnisse weitergeben
und werden dazu in zwei lokale
Bäckereibetriebe aufgeteilt.
Fehlen ein paar Sachen?
- Ja, Trockenfrüchte ...
... Nüsse, Speck ...
Also ja,
Speck können wir dort kaufen.
Butter haben wir auch keine.
Zusammen
mit ihren ruandischen Kolleginnen
sollen sie heute
Kuchen und Brote backen,
die übermorgen an der Diplomfeier
von Jackie Helfenbergers Schule
aufgetischt werden.
Vielleicht wisst ihr es schon:
Wir haben in Nyamasheke
die erste Diplomfeier unserer Hotel-
fachschule mit 120 Studierenden.
Wir müssen 300 Gäste verköstigen.
Ziel ist also,
dass wir ganz viel Brot und Kuchen
für die Leute dort in Nyamasheke
produzieren.
Die zweite Gruppe
arbeitet in der modernen Schau-
bäckerei eines grossen Supermarktes.
Hier fehlt es an nichts.
Schau kurz rein.
Kannst du mir zeigen, wie?
Die Handgriffe sitzen wie zu Hause.
Diese Gruppe stellt die Sandwichbrote
für die Diplomfeier her.
Okay.
Jackie nutzt die Zeit
für ein weiteres Treffen.
Es geht dabei
um ihre Tourismusschule,
die sie vor zwei Jahren im Süden
des Landes ins Leben gerufen hat.
In zwei Tagen werden dort die ersten
120 Hotelangestellten diplomiert.
Damit alles seine Richtigkeit hat,
trifft sich Jackie Helfenberger heute
mit der Ministerin für Berufsbildung.
Denn noch immer fehlt die
offizielle Akkreditierung der Schule.
Unser Team
hat nun alle Unterlagen eingereicht.
Der Registrierungsprozess
läuft also.
Der zweite Lehrgang mit
ca. 100 Studierenden startet gerade.
Die erste Gruppe
wird am 13. Juli diplomiert.
Okay.
Das ist ein wichtiges Gespräch, oder?
Ja, ja. Doch, doch.
Es ist gut zu wissen,
wer schon über die Sangira-Schule
in Nyamasheke Bescheid weiss,
und wer noch nicht.
Es wissen schon viele Bescheid,
aber es gibt noch
ein paar Lücken und Puzzleteile,
die es zu füllen gilt.
Sieht es gut aus
für die Akkreditierung?
Ja, es sieht gut aus. Ja.
In der modernen Schaubäckerei läuft
derweil alles wie am Schnürchen.
Noch nicht gut?
- Doch. Zum Glück.
Die ersten Gugelhopfe sind fertig.
Sie sehen so aus wie in der Schweiz.
Bei der anderen Gruppe hingegen
geht es
noch etwas gemütlicher zu und her.
Oh mein Gott. Ich glaube ...
Es läuft über.
* Lachen *
Also, 350 g.
Was hast du in der Hand?
Wir haben nach einem Löffel gefragt,
aber sie fanden keinen.
Dafür aber eine Grillzange
mit nur einer Zange.
Wir machen es damit.
- Geht auch.- Ja.
Wir brauchen einfach etwas,
um es rauszunehmen.
Grillzangen statt Löffel,
ein Gasherd ohne Gas -
Not macht erfinderisch.
Was macht ihr jetzt hier?
Die Butter schmelzen,
weil wir kein Gas haben.
Das geht schon.
- Die Sonne ist stark.
Und dann auch noch
ein Ofen voller Überraschungen.
Da ist noch Brot drin.
* Lachen *
Habt ihr noch etwas gefunden?
Doch die Bäckerinnen aus der Schweiz
lassen sich
nicht aus der Ruhe bringen.
Sie nutzen die Zeit zum Austausch von
Rezepten, wie z.B. einer Rüeblitorte.
Die schnell wachsende Mittelschicht
in der Hauptstadt Kigali
verlangt immer mehr
nach Brot und Backwaren.
Einen Monat werden die jungen
Schweizerinnen in Ruanda sein.
Sie kommen
von überall aus der Schweiz
und haben für diesen Austausch
z.T. auch Ferien hingegeben.
Im Gespräch mit ihren ruandischen
Berufskolleginnen lernen sie,
dass man Rosinen
nicht überall auf der Welt kennt.
* Lachen *
Das ist auseinandergefallen.
No, it's not good.
- Immer noch nicht?
Sie alle haben sich
für den Austausch entschieden,
um ihr Wissen weiterzugeben
und selber von der fremden Kultur
etwas mitzunehmen.
Is it okay?
No?
Ich glaube,
die werden ziemlich trocken sein.
Und sei es nur das Improvisieren -
z.B., wenn es um den Abwasch geht.
Gut Ding will Weile haben.
Nach zweieinhalb Stunden
ist es endlich so weit.
Es ist gut -
wie normale Schokoladenmuffins.
Sicher gut.
Wir hatten etwas Angst,
dass sie sehr trocken werden,
weil sie so lange drin waren.
Aber ich glaube, die sind gut so.
- Super.
Und langsam
erschliesst sich mir auch der Grund,
warum Bäcker Olivier
einen neuen Ofen bauen will.
Zum Abschluss des Tages
der verdiente Apéro
in gediegener Atmosphäre.
Ein bisschen Grossstadt,
bevor es morgen weitergeht aufs Land.
Die Reise
beginnt im Stau von Kigali ...
... bevor sie uns
immer weiter hinauf ins Grüne führt.
Bald wird klar, warum Ruanda
auch das Land der tausend Hügel
oder die Schweiz Afrikas
genannt wird.
8 Std. Fahrt führen uns
durch abgelegene Dörfer ...
... und einmal
quer durch den Dschungel.
Entlang der Grenze Burundis ...
... vorbei an Affen ...
... und verunfallten Lastwagen.
Aha!
- Was ist passiert?
* Ruhige Musik *
Ein kurzer Fotostopp
in den berühmten Teeplantagen ...
... und dann endlich
kommt der Kiwusee in Sichtweite.
Gerade als die Sonne hinter
den Hügeln des Kongos verschwindet,
erreichen wir endlich das Ziel.
Wir packen mal aus
und gehen dann essen,
wenn alles ausgepackt ist.
Das finde ich gut.
Und dann beginnt der Tag, auf den
alle schon lange hingearbeitet haben:
Die ersten Tourismusfachleute
von Jackie Helfenbergers Schule
werden diplomiert.
Auf dem Festgelände
laufen die letzten Vorbereitungen.
Mehrere hundert Gäste
aus den höchsten Rängen von Regierung
und Militär werden erwartet.
Zur gleichen Zeit
steigt in den Räumlichkeiten
der Tourismusschule die Nervosität.
* Telefon *
Ja, was ist?
Jackie hat alle Hände voll zu tun.
Die Sangira-T-Shirts sind
beim Fenster auf der rechten Seite.
Dort ist der Koffer.
Welche Farbe? Keine Ahnung.
Auch die 150 Paar Schuhe aus der
Schweiz müssen noch verteilt werden.
Nebenan stürzen sich die Diplomanden
in ihre Roben.
Auch die Bäckerinnen sind
schon lange wieder an der Arbeit.
Es braucht noch mehr Brote,
damit es für alle Gäste reicht.
Wir sind jetzt noch daran,
die langen Sandwiches zu füllen.
Das Brot
haben wir schon vorbereitet.
Jetzt füllen wir es noch
mit Avocado, Tomaten und Schinken.
Die Organisation
war einfach etwas schwierig.
Also, die Pünktlichkeit
war wieder nicht da.
Wir hatten nicht alle Materialien,
keine Maschinen ...
D.h.,
wir haben alles von Hand gemacht.
Es ging viel länger
als normalerweise,
aber sonst
hat es sehr gut funktioniert.
Grösstenteils kam es gut raus.
- Bist du zufrieden? Zeig mal.
Dafür, dass wir sie hier
und ohne Teigmaschine gemacht haben,
gab es ein paar sehr schöne.
Auf dem Festgelände
sitzen die Eltern und Verwandten
längst auf ihren Plätzen.
Und die Band
spielt sich schon Mal ein.
Nebenan begrüsst Jackie Helfenberger
im Schatten der Bäume alle VIP-Gäste.
And you?
* Unverständlich *
And what's your name?
Malik ist der Honorarkonsul
für Ruanda in Tschechien.
In Tschechien?
- Czech Republic, yeah.
Anna Dali ist
die Bürgermeisterin von Nyamasheke.
Bürgermeisterin.
- Anna Dali, hm?
Bürgermeisterin - mayor.
- Bürgermeister? Mayor?
That's German. Bürgermeister.
- Bürgermeister, yeah.
Benoît.
Benoît? Er ist ...
C'est quoi ton titre?
- First Commander.
Der First Commander von Nyamasheke.
- First Commander from Nyamasheke.
First Commander from Nyamasheke.
- From the district.
Richard dort drüben ist der Colonel.
The CO, Commanding Officer.
- Der CO.
Commanding Officer. Entschuldigung,
mit dem Militär ist es schwierig.
Dann haben wir Joseph.
Er ist
Business-Development-Minister.
Yes.
- Yes.- Für Nyamasheke.
Es ist wichtig
diese Leute zu kennen, nicht?
Es ist wichtig,
diese Leute zu kennen.
Wir arbeiten Hand in Hand.
Es ist nicht nur für Nyamasheke
wichtig.
Davon profitiert
die ganze Hotelindustrie Ruandas.
Die richtigen Menschen zu kennen,
hilft auch in Ruanda.
Auf dem Papier
ist das Land zwar eine Demokratie.
De facto liegt die Macht
aber seit dem Genozid
in den Händen einer einzigen Partei.
Stramm unterstützt vom Militär,
das immer und überall sichtbar ist -
natürlich auch, wenn gefeiert wird.
* Jubel *
* Rhythmische Musik *
All diese jungen Menschen erhalten
heute ihr Diplom als Hotelfachkräfte.
Neun Monate haben sie gelernt,
wie man Gäste begrüsst, Betten macht,
kocht oder Essen serviert.
Sie kommen
aus ärmlichen Verhältnissen
und haben dank Jackie Helfenbergers
Sangira-Stiftung
umsonst eine Ausbildung erhalten.
Von den 120 Abgängern
haben alle einen Arbeitsvertrag
mit einem Hotel unterzeichnet
und halten damit ein Ticket
für eine bessere Zukunft in der Hand.
Es ist megaschön und die Trommeln
gehen total ins Herz.
Das muss man erlebt haben.
* Applaus *
* Sie spricht ruandisch. *
* Applaus, Trommeln *
Ich gratuliere den Studierenden
für die harte Arbeit,
die sie geleistet haben.
Thank you so much.
Ich weiss jetzt auch,
wofür ich so hart gearbeitet habe.
Dieser wunderschöne Moment
gibt mir sehr viel zurück.
Herzlichen Dank.
Schon in wenigen Tagen beginnt in
Jackie Helfenbergers Hotellerieschule
der nächste Lehrgang.
Sie selber
wird zurück in die Schweiz reisen,
um weiter
für ihr Herzensprojekt zu sammeln.
Das rauschende Fest
dauert noch bis tief in die Nacht ...
... und vereint die Lernwilligen
aus zwei Kontinenten.
* Rhythmische Musik
und afrikanischer Gesang *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023